This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For many people, this is what works sounds like nowadays. It's a constant thromb of notifications, tweets and messages. Every time we respond to an email or a text or Google a question that's just popped into our head, we pay a small price. In the moment, this price is imperceptible, but over time, it adds up, and we haven't quite come to terms with the cost of constant distraction. We treat it, I think, in this more general sense of, I probably should be less distracted, and I think it's more urgent than people realize. This week on Hidden Brain, we continue our annual summer series,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。对许多人来说，这就是当今“工作”的样子。它是通知、推文和消息的持续轰炸。每当我们回复一封电子邮件、一条短信，或者用谷歌搜索一个刚出现在脑海里的问题时，我们都要付出一点代价。在当下，这种代价是难以察觉的，但随着时间的推移，它会累积起来，而我们还没有完全意识到这种持续分心所带来的成本。我认为，我们以一种更笼统的方式对待它，觉得“我可能应该少分心一点”，但我认为这比人们意识到的更为紧迫。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将继续我们的年度夏季系列节目，
YouTube.com. Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. Let me do it. Just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. This episode, we explore ways to immerse ourselves in meaningful work.
YouTube.com。真实性具有感染力。我一直被拖入这一切，又踢又叫。关于如何应对生活混乱的想法和建议。让我来做吧。只要检查一下我的收件箱。只要检查一下，只要检查一下，只要快速检查一下我的手机。带着智慧。这一集，我们将探索让自己沉浸在有意义工作中的方法。
Today we look at the challenge of cultivating deep attention and what we gain by immersing ourselves in meaningful work. I spoke to someone who might seem like an unlikely advocate for technological restraint, a computer scientist. Cal Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. He's deliberately tried to break away from the distractions of modern technology, and he's trying to get the rest of us to follow his lead. Cal is the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal, welcome to Hidden Brain.
今天，我们探讨培养深度注意力的挑战，以及通过沉浸在有意义的工作中我们能获得什么。我采访了一位看起来不太可能成为技术克制倡导者的人，一位计算机科学家。卡尔·纽波特是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授。他刻意尝试摆脱现代技术的干扰，并试图让我们其他人跟随他的脚步。卡尔是《深度工作：在分心世界中获得卓越成就的法则》一书的作者。卡尔，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Well, thanks for having me on. You're talking about several highly influential thinkers, people like the psychiatrist Carl Jung, the writers Mark Twain, Jackie Rowling, and you see they all have a set of habits that are quite striking in terms of how they're able to get great work done. This was something I noticed to very common to influential thinkers, is that they all seem to have this drive to on a regular basis, cut themselves off from their lives of busyness and communication and distraction, and isolate themselves to think deeply. What do they do specifically? Well, what you'll notice is that they often
嗯，谢谢你邀请我。你谈到了几位极具影响力的思想家，比如精神病学家卡尔·荣格，作家马克·吐温、J.K.罗琳，你会发现他们都有一套非常引人注目的习惯，关于他们如何能够完成伟大的工作。这是我注意到非常有影响力的思想家所共有的东西，那就是他们似乎都有这种动力，定期将自己从忙碌、交流和分心的生活中切断，并孤立自己进行深度思考。他们具体做了什么？嗯，你会注意到他们经常
will have a location, a separate location they go to when they want to think deeply, that's often cut off from the rest of their life. So Carl Jung would go out to the Balanjian Tower, a stone house without electricity or running water he built by the lake side outside of a small village in the countryside beyond Zurich. JK Rowling, when she was struggling to finish the Deathly Hallows, rented out this big suite at the Belmore Hotel next to the big castle in downtown Edinburgh, where she'd go and just think Harry Potter style thoughts. Mark Twain had a cabin for a long period of his life. He would go to on the property of their house. It was so far from the house that his
会有一个地点，一个他们想要深度思考时会去的独立地点，这通常与他们的日常生活隔绝。所以卡尔·荣格会去博林根塔，那是他在苏黎世郊外一个小村庄旁的湖边建造的一座没有电也没有自来水的石屋。J.K.罗琳在努力完成《死亡圣器》时，租下了爱丁堡市中心城堡旁边巴尔莫勒尔酒店的一个大套房，她会在那里去思考哈利·波特式的想法。马克·吐温在他生命中的很长一段时间里都有一个小木屋。他会去他们房子地产上的那个小木屋。它离房子太远了，以至于他的
family had to blow a horn that tried to catch his attention and let him know that dinner was ready. They go somewhere physically isolated and different where they can without distraction think deeply. What does work look like for the rest of us? When you look at the average American worker for example, are most of us doing this kind of deep, sustained work? The type of deep work I talk about is almost non-existent as far as I can tell, in most knowledge work positions, even when people think that they're single-tasking. They say, I've learned a lesson that I'm not supposed to multitask. I'm not supposed to be on the phone and do email while I write.
家人不得不吹响号角来引起他的注意，让他知道晚餐准备好了。他们去了一个物理上孤立且不同的地方，在那里他们可以不受干扰地进行深度思考。对于我们其他人来说，工作是什么样的？例如，当你观察普通的美国工人时，我们大多数人是否在做这种深度、持续的工作？据我所知，我所说的这种深度工作在大多数知识型工作岗位中几乎是不存在的，即使人们认为他们是在进行单任务处理。他们说，我学到了一个教训，我不应该多任务处理。我不应该在写作时打电话和处理电子邮件。
I'm just working on one thing at a time. What they're still doing is every five or ten minutes, a just check. Let me just check to my inbox. Let me just do a just check to my phone real quick and then back to my work. And it feels like single task. And it feels like you're predominantly working on one thing. But even those very brief checks that switch your context even briefly can have this massive negative impact on your cognitive performance, is to switch itself that hurts, not how long
我一次只做一件事。但他们仍然在做的是每五或十分钟，就“检查一下”。让我检查一下我的收件箱。让我快速检查一下我的手机，然后回到我的工作中。这感觉像是单任务处理。感觉你主要是在做一件事。但即使是那些非常短暂的、切换你语境的检查，也会对你的认知表现产生巨大的负面影响，是切换本身造成了伤害，而不是你切换了多久
you actually switch. So I actually think even very conscientious knowledge workers who think they're pretty good at focusing on one thing at a time are actually still working far from the sort of high-performance deep work ideal. What is the evidence that the switching causes harm to the quality of your thinking? Well we've seen the show up in different types of scientific studies and from different types of perspectives. I think one angle that makes it pretty clear
你实际上切换了。所以我认为，即使是非常认真的知识工作者，认为自己很擅长一次专注于一件事，实际上仍然远离那种高性能深度工作的理想状态。有什么证据表明这种切换会对你的思维质量造成损害？嗯，我们已经在不同类型的科学研究中看到了这一点，并从不同的角度进行了观察。我认为一个让这一点变得非常清楚的角度
is the work that Professor Sophie Leroy has done on an effect called attention residue. This is actually something that's pretty easy to isolate in the laboratory. You essentially give a subject something cognitively demanding to do that you can measure, like trying to solve hard puzzles. And then at some point, you distract them briefly
是索菲·勒罗伊教授在一种被称为“注意力残留”的效应上所做的工作。这实际上是在实验室中很容易隔离的东西。你基本上给受试者一些认知上要求很高且可以测量的事情去做，比如尝试解决难题。然后在某个时刻，你简短地分散他们的注意力
as the experimenter. Have them look at something else else change their context very briefly when they then turn back to the original Cogeley demanding task you see the performance drops and it drops for a while It takes a while for this attention residue to clear out and this is essentially what we're doing to ourselves When we do that quick glance at the inbox or to the phone Cal I'm wondering do you think most of us are aware of the costs of distraction in our lives? People, I think, intuit that they're too distracted
作为实验者。让他们看别的东西，非常简短地改变他们的语境，当他们转回最初那个认知要求很高的任务时，你会发现表现下降了，而且下降了一段时间。这种注意力残留需要一段时间才能清除，而这基本上就是我们在进行那种对收件箱或手机的快速一瞥时对自己所做的事情。卡尔，我想知道你是否认为我们大多数人意识到了生活中分心的代价？人们，我认为，直觉上感觉到他们太分心了
and it's making them feel fragmented and exhausted and anxious, but we treat it, I think, in this more general sense of, I probably should be less distracted, and I think it's more urgent than people realize that if your brain is how you make a living, then you really have to worry about this cognitive fitness. I mean, how are you getting performance out of your brain? Are you taking care to get good performance out of your brain or not? And people would probably be surprised to the more they think about it, how much they leave in on
这让他们感到支离破碎、精疲力竭和焦虑，但我们以一种更笼统的方式对待它，觉得“我可能应该少分心一点”，但我认为这比人们意识到的更为紧迫，如果你的大脑是你谋生的工具，那么你真的必须担心这种认知健康。我的意思是，你是如何从你的大脑中获得表现的？你是否在注意从你的大脑中获得良好的表现？如果人们多思考一下，他们可能会对自己在目前的工作方式下浪费了多少潜力感到惊讶。
the table by the way they're currently working right now. I understand that folks at Atlantic Media once tried to quantify the financial cost of email, the amount of time people spend reading and responding to email. Yeah, it was the CTO of Atlantic Media at the time did this study where they actually went through and calculated how many emails people were receiving, how long the average email was, what their average reading speed was, so he could contemplate or calculate how many hours were being spent collectively, then he cross-tabulated that with their salary, which he could then calculate what's their effective hourly rate, and figured out that basically they were spending about the price of a lear jet every year
我了解到大西洋媒体公司的人曾经试图量化电子邮件的财务成本，即人们花费在阅读和回复电子邮件上的时间。是的，当时大西洋媒体公司的首席技术官做了这项研究，他们实际上计算了人们收到了多少封电子邮件，平均每封邮件有多长，他们的平均阅读速度是多少，这样他就可以思考或计算出集体花费了多少小时，然后他将其与他们的工资进行了交叉制表，从而计算出他们的有效时薪，并发现基本上他们每年花费大约一架里尔喷气机的价格
paying people to send and receive emails. Well, most of us, I think when we think about email, we actually imagine that addressing, handling, responding to 25 emails, 30 emails, maybe 100 emails every day, that's just part of our job. We actually think of it as actually being part of our productivity. You're making the argument that potentially, this is a cost that we're paying that actually
支付人们发送和接收电子邮件。嗯，我们大多数人，我认为当我们想到电子邮件时，我们实际上认为处理、应对25封、30封，也许每天100封电子邮件，那只是我们工作的一部分。我们实际上认为这是我们生产力的一部分。你提出的论点是，潜在地，这是我们正在支付的成本，实际上
impedes our productivity. No one's ever made a fortune by being really good at sending and receiving emails. I think right now, where the early stages of digital knowledge work, we've adopted this workflow that's very convenient and very simple, which is let's just give an email address to every person and let work unfold in this sort of ad hoc ongoing conversation that happens with this message is going back and forth and back and forth. And it's very easy and it's very convenient, but it's also drastically reducing the human brains that are the main resource of these organizations. So my way of thinking about this is that we've built up a culture of convenience and simplicity in knowledge work at the cost of effectiveness and true
阻碍了我们的生产力。没有人因为非常擅长发送和接收电子邮件而发财。我认为现在，我们处于数字知识工作的早期阶段，我们采用了这种非常方便且非常简单的工作流程，那就是给每个人一个电子邮件地址，让工作在这种随意的、持续的对话中展开，消息来回发送。这非常容易，也非常方便，但它也极大地削弱了作为这些组织主要资源的人类大脑。所以我对这件事的看法是，我们以牺牲效率和真正的
productivity and this is something that we need to change. Does it matter that most of us are not trying to win a Nobel Prize or a Pulitzer Prize that we're not necessarily geniuses? Does it actually matter for most of us that we don't regularly put ourselves in a state of deep work? Well, this is a big shift that I think has happened in our economy because it's an increasing portion of our economy that are essentially making a living by using their brain to process information and produce new information. And even if you're not trying to write great literature or solve a great theorem, if you're using your brain primarily to produce value, be it writing
生产力为代价，在知识工作中建立了一种便利和简单的文化，这是我们需要改变的事情。我们大多数人并不是为了赢得诺贝尔奖或普利策奖，我们不一定是天才，这重要吗？对于我们大多数人来说，不定期让自己处于深度工作状态，这真的重要吗？嗯，这是一个我认为在我们的经济中已经发生的巨大转变，因为我们经济中越来越多的部分基本上是通过使用大脑来处理信息和产生新信息来谋生的。即使你不是试图写出伟大的文学作品或解决伟大的定理，如果你主要使用你的大脑来产生价值，无论是撰写
marketing copy or putting together a new plan for your business start up, these type of things matter. The human brain has become one of the main capital resources in our economy. It's what in the knowledge economy we spend most of our money on is supporting human brains to process things and produce value. So we should care. I think the ability to deep work would be relevant to the professional success of almost everyone in the knowledge work field, which is a huge part of our economy.
营销文案还是为你的商业初创公司制定新计划，这些类型的事情都很重要。人类大脑已成为我们经济中的主要资本资源之一。在知识经济中，我们大部分资金都花在支持人类大脑处理事物和产生价值上。所以我们应该关心。我认为深度工作的能力与知识工作领域中几乎每个人的职业成功都相关，这是我们经济的很大一部分。
I'd like to run a little thought experiment. Imagine we're following a doctor as she's making the rounds of a hospital and she's looking at many patients and presumably the patients all present with different problems and complications and so forth. And I think what we would expect is for this doctor to very quickly flip from one subject, one topic, one patient to the next. That if we, if the doctor were to say, you know, I can only do my best work. If I can focus on one patient, deeply understand that case, spend a lot of time with it. Yes, that might be true, but it's going to come at a cost, which is all the other patients that the doctor is not going to see. What are the costs of deep work?
我想做一个小小的思想实验。想象一下，我们跟随一位医生在医院查房，她正在看许多病人，据推测，病人们都表现出不同的问题和并发症等等。我认为我们所期望的是这位医生非常迅速地从一个主题、一个话题、一个病人切换到下一个。如果医生说，你知道，我只有在能专注于一个病人，深入了解那个病例，花很多时间在上面时，才能做到最好的工作。是的，这可能是真的，但这将付出代价，那就是医生将无法看到的其他所有病人。深度工作的代价是什么？
Well, where I'd want to get with the doctor is just the ability, even if you're relatively briefly staying with each patient, to actually be able to stay just with that patient. So a case study I uncovered actually after the book came out was of two different groups at the same Elite level residency. One group had a culture of email. So hey, I need something here's a question. What about this patient? And they're expected that the constantly be available by email. The other group Consolidated that type of administrative or logistical conversations to set meetings. And what the doctor from that hospital told me is that they had a real hard time keeping people in type of administrative or logistical conversations to set meetings.
嗯，我想和医生探讨的是这种能力，即使你与每个病人相处的时间相对较短，也能真正做到只专注于那个病人。我在书出版后发现的一个案例研究是关于同一精英住院医师项目的两个不同小组。一组有电子邮件文化。所以，嘿，我需要一些东西，这里有个问题。这个病人怎么样？他们被期望随时可以通过电子邮件联系。另一组将那种行政或后勤对话整合到设定的会议中。那位医院的医生告诉我，他们很难让人们保持在
And what the doctor from that hospital told me is that they had a real hard time keeping people in that first group, where in the second group people were much happier. So deep work doesn't necessarily mean I can sit half a day and just think about this one patient, but just the ability to walk into a room and just think about that patient and not have to see 16 emails as you walk into the next room and have that eating away at your attention, that can really make a big difference. You said that the people who were engaged in deep work ended up being happier, so it's
那种行政或后勤对话中以设定会议。那位医院的医生告诉我，他们很难让第一组的人保持专注，而在第二组，人们要快乐得多。所以深度工作并不一定意味着我可以坐半天只思考这一个病人，但仅仅是走进一个房间只思考那个病人，而不必在走进下一个房间时看到16封电子邮件，并让它蚕食你的注意力，这真的能产生很大的不同。你说那些从事深度工作的人最终更快乐，所以这
not just a question of being more productive, but you're making the case that deep work produces a kind of intrinsic reward that doesn't come from being distracted? It seems to. In fact, this caught me off guard when I was researching my book. I ended up adding a chapter to the book that was not in the original proposal. That was all about these findings. I kept coming across, and these stories I kept coming across, about deep living, also just being good living.
不仅仅是一个生产力更高的问题，你还在论证深度工作产生了一种不会来自被分心的内在奖励？似乎是这样。事实上，当我在研究我的书时，这让我措手不及。我最终在书中增加了一个最初提案中没有的章节。那全是关于这些发现的。我不断遇到这些发现，以及我不断遇到的关于深度生活的故事，它们也是美好的生活。
People who spend a larger proportion of the professional time concentrating intensely on a single high skill or high craft target tend to enjoy their work a lot more. There's a lot of different factors about why that might be true, but I ended by saying a deep life is a good life. And that's something I really believe in. It can take a knowledge work career and make it much more satisfying than being in a persistent state of putting out fires and busy distraction. Can you cite any professions where deep work
那些将更大比例的职业时间集中在单一高技能或高工艺目标上的人往往更享受他们的工作。关于为什么这可能是真的，有很多不同的因素，但我最后说，深度生活是美好的生活。这是我真正相信的事情。它可以让知识工作生涯变得比处于持续的“救火”和忙碌分心状态中要满足得多。你能列举出哪些职业是深度工作
is probably not called for and might even be a problem? Sure, there's plenty of examples I think where deep work is probably not that relevant. A couple of the common examples I give is actually, I think being a CEO of a large company, you're probably going to better serve your company or stockholders by being a decision engine for other people who are doing deep work. Someone who people can come to, okay, what about this, what should we do here?
可能不需要，甚至可能是一个问题的吗？当然，我认为有很多例子说明深度工作可能并不那么相关。我给出的几个常见例子实际上是，我认为作为一家大公司的首席执行官，你可能通过成为那些正在进行深度工作的人的决策引擎，更好地服务于你的公司或股东。一个人们可以来找的人，好的，这个怎么样，我们在这里应该做什么？
You can be a consistent source of the vision and push these decisions in a consistent way. Another example is, let's say you're in what they would call here in DC, government relations, where really most of what you do is context and connections and connecting the right people to the right other people and keeping up with what's going on in people's lives. That's another example of a place where long solitary concentration is not going to make a difference. I think there's plenty of jobs, in other words, in which deep work doesn't make a difference. But I've also found, in my experience, that the number of jobs for which this is true is smaller than people expect. It seems to me that there are connections here with ideas related to mindfulness, or ideas
你可以成为愿景的一致来源，并以一致的方式推动这些决策。另一个例子是，假设你处于华盛顿所说的政府关系部门，你所做的大部分工作实际上是语境和联系，将合适的人与合适的其他人联系起来，并跟上人们生活中发生的事情。这是另一个长期孤独的专注不会产生影响的地方。换句话说，我认为有很多工作，深度工作不会产生影响。但根据我的经验，我也发现，这种情况适用的工作数量比人们预期的要少。在我看来，这里与正念相关的想法，或者想法
related to flow that you should be in the moment focused on what you're doing. It seems to me that those ideas are intimately connected with deep work. They are connected. So DeepWork can induce flow states, which is one of the reasons why people find a career push more towards DeepWork is more satisfying. It's not entirely synonymous with flow. We know there's other types of states that also count as DeepWork that would not fall under most definitions of flow.
与心流相关，即你应该专注于你正在做的事情，这些想法似乎与深度工作密切相关。它们是相关的。所以深度工作可以诱发心流状态，这就是为什么人们发现职业更倾向于深度工作会更令人满意的原因之一。它并不完全等同于心流。我们知道还有其他类型的状态也算作深度工作，这些状态不属于大多数心流的定义。
So for example, being in a state of deliberate practice where you're systematically pushing your skills past where you're comfortable so that you can improve, that's different than a flow state. It doesn't feel pleasurable. You don't lose yourself in the time. When you're practicing like that, you feel every single second because it's very difficult. But that also falls under the umbrella of deep work. And what about mindfulness? The idea that we should just be immersed in what we are doing, paying attention to what's going on in the moment. There are connections to mindfulness. And one of the more important connections is that we know from the study and practice
例如，处于刻意练习的状态，即你系统地将你的技能推向你舒适区之外，以便你可以改进，这与心流状态不同。它感觉并不令人愉悦。你不会在时间中迷失自己。当你那样练习时，你感受每一秒，因为它非常困难。但这也在深度工作的范畴之内。那么正念呢？我们应该沉浸在我们正在做的事情中，关注当下发生的事情的想法。这与正念有联系。其中一个更重要的联系是，我们从研究和实践中知道
of mindfulness, such as mindfulness meditation, that getting better at that type of presence is something that requires practice and training. And we see this exactly happening with deep work and a professional setting. It's something that you train and get better at, just like you can get better at certain types of meditation, that it's something you have to work at systematically. It's a skill to be practiced, not a habit that you already know how to do and just try to make more time for. When we come back, we'll talk about how you can retrain your mind to focus, to set with a single idea for a long period of time.
正念，例如正念冥想，那种在那种存在感上变得更好是需要练习和训练的。我们在深度工作和专业环境中也看到了这一点。这是一种你训练并变得更好的东西，就像你可以通过某些类型的冥想变得更好一样，这是你必须系统地努力去做的事情。这是一项需要练习的技能，而不是你已经知道如何做并只是试图腾出更多时间的习惯。当我们回来时，我们将讨论你如何重新训练你的大脑去专注，去长时间地坐下来思考一个单一的想法。
And we'll talk about whether creating a deep work culture for some people means that others will inevitably have to pick up the slack. Stay with us. I'm speaking to Cal Newport, a Georgetown University computer science professor who's the author of the book Deep Work. It's about how we can cultivate the ability to focus on work, free of all distraction. Cal leads an enormously disciplined life with lots of rules and rituals. I asked him to explain how he structures his day to allow plenty of time for focused
我们将讨论为某些人创造深度工作文化是否意味着其他人将不可避免地不得不承担额外的工作。请留下来。我正在与乔治城大学计算机科学教授卡尔·纽波特交谈，他是《深度工作》一书的作者。它是关于我们如何培养专注于工作的能力，摆脱所有干扰。卡尔过着极其自律的生活，有很多规则和仪式。我请他解释他是如何安排自己的一天，以留出充足的时间进行专注的
work. There's a few things I do. One is I've never had a social media account, and that's on purpose. It's not that I think I'm better than social media, but to quote George Packer's essay on this is because I'm afraid I'll let my kids go hungry if I expose myself to that George Packer's essay on this, it's because I'm afraid I'll let my kids go hungry if I expose myself to that. So that's one thing I do. Two, I'm very organized with my time.
工作。我做几件事。第一，我从来没有社交媒体账户，这是故意的。并不是我觉得我比社交媒体更好，而是引用乔治·帕克关于这个的文章，是因为我担心如果我让自己接触到那个，我会让我的孩子挨饿。所以这是我做的一件事。第二，我对我的时间非常有组织。
I work during very set hours during the day and I plan out the day like a chess player moving the pieces around. This is when I'm going to work on win. I don't let my mood dictate how my day unfolds. And then three, I've made myself very comfortable with annoying people. I'm bad at email. I have just set the expectations that I'm just not available a lot. I'm not someone that you can expect a quick answer from.
我在一天中非常固定的时间工作，我像一个移动棋子的棋手一样规划这一天。这是我将要工作的时间。我不让我的情绪支配我的一天如何展开。然后第三，我让自己非常习惯于惹恼别人。我不擅长电子邮件。我只是设定了期望，即我没有太多时间。我不是那种你可以期待快速回答的人。
And that also causes some trouble, of course, but all this adds up to allowing me to regularly have long portions of many of my days focused on deeper thinking. I understand you actually keep a tally of how much deep work you've done, how many hours you've spent being uninterrupted, and you actually have targets that you must meet at the end of the day or the end of the week. Yeah, that's right. This is something I, until recently I was doing, I was tallying, you know, how many deep
当然，这也造成了一些麻烦，但所有这些加起来让我能够定期在我的许多天里有很长一段时间专注于更深入的思考。我了解到你实际上记录了你完成了多少深度工作，你花了多少小时不被打断，而且你实际上有必须在一天结束或一周结束时达到的目标。是的，没错。这是我直到最近才做的事情，我一直在统计，你知道，多少深度
work hours, so I had to confront that. I had to confront the reality. So if I was really avoiding deep work, I would see it. I've since added a new habit to my arsenal here where I now block out my deep work on my calendar up to four weeks in advance. So I have that time protected so far out in the future that I can be sure it'll stay protected. So now I have a record on my calendar of exactly what deep work I'm doing. Do people call you obsessive or basically say, you know, you're redded too much to your calendar? People do. People also seem, which surprises me, worried that that would somehow diminish creativity, that somehow having structure in your schedule means you're not going to be able to do unstructured speaking thinking. But what I found is actually quite the opposite, being able to protect my time and to have long periods of undistracted
工作时间，所以我必须面对它。我必须面对现实。所以如果我真的在逃避深度工作，我会看到的。我后来在我的武器库中增加了一个新习惯，我现在在我的日历上提前四周屏蔽我的深度工作。所以我把那个时间保护得离未来很远，以至于我可以确定它会保持受保护。所以现在我的日历上有一个我正在做的深度工作的记录。人们称你为强迫症，或者基本上说，你知道，你太依赖你的日历了？人们确实会。人们似乎也，这让我感到惊讶，担心这会以某种方式削弱创造力，担心在你的日程安排中有结构意味着你将无法进行非结构化的思考。但我发现实际上恰恰相反，能够保护我的时间并拥有长时间的不受干扰的
time allows me to be a lot more creative. So I often push back on that particular critique that if I was just sort of ad hoc checking emails and social media and in a state of semi-destruction all day, I would probably be much less creative than my more structured approach. I understand you have a fairly structured approach to shutting down at the end of the day of making sure that the tasks that remain unfinished don't bleed into your evening and your family life. I have an actual ritual I do at the end of each workday
时间让我更有创造力。所以我经常反驳那个特定的批评，如果我只是整天随意地检查电子邮件和社交媒体，处于半破坏状态，我可能会比我更有结构的方法创造力低得多。我了解到你在一天结束时有一个相当结构化的关闭方法，以确保未完成的任务不会蔓延到你的晚上和家庭生活中。我确实有一个我在每个工作日结束时做的实际仪式
where it pretty systematically, I'll look at my weekly plan, I'll look at my task licks. I'll look at my calendar Make sure that nothing is left hanging and then I'll do a little shutdown mantra You'll say an actual phrase that means I'm now done work for the day What's the phrase that you tell yourself at the end of the day? I used to be embarrassed to admit the phrase was Schedule shutdown complete, but I now have this small but strong fan group that used that exact same phrase proudly.
我非常系统地查看我的每周计划，查看我的任务列表。我会查看我的日历，确保没有任何事情悬而未决，然后我会做一个小小的关闭咒语。你会说一个实际的短语，意味着我现在完成了这一天的工作。你对自己说的短语是什么？我过去很尴尬地承认这个短语是“日程关闭完成”，但我现在有一个虽小但强大的粉丝群，他们自豪地使用了完全相同的短语。
So now I'm willing to admit, it's schedule shutdown complete. Do you say this without this around? No. It doesn't really matter what the phrase is. I invented that phrase when I was a graduate student working on my dissertation. It was really having a hard time with coming home from the office and having all these concerns, hey, what if this proof never fixes or what if this proof breaks, what if my dissertation falls apart? And I needed something to allow
所以现在我愿意承认，它是“日程关闭完成”。你是在没有人的情况下说这个吗？不。短语是什么并不重要。我在读研究生写论文时发明了这个短语。我真的很难从办公室回家，并有所有这些担忧，嘿，如果这个证明永远修不好怎么办，或者如果这个证明坏了怎么办，如果我的论文分崩离析怎么办？我需要一些东西来允许
me to definitively shut down. And so I was younger then, I came up with this phrase, but now it became habit, so I stuck with it. Cal, what would you say to people who say, you're asking us to turn into computers, you're asking us to behave like robots? Well, see, I would argue that that's what people are doing right now. We've turned ourselves into sort of human network routers. We just sit here and process messages
我明确地关闭。所以我那时更年轻，我想出了这个短语，但现在它成了习惯，所以我坚持了下来。卡尔，你会对那些说“你要求我们变成电脑，你要求我们像机器人一样行事”的人说什么？嗯，你看，我会争辩说这就是人们现在正在做的事情。我们已经把自己变成了某种人类网络路由器。我们只是坐在这里处理消息
and sort through task lists and have the sense of busyness that treats our mind like a digital computer processor. Something that you just feed instructions to and it executes one after another, I think what I'm doing is actually way more human. This idea that our brain is not like a computer, it's not like any other machine we know, it's something that you have a personal connection to
并整理任务列表，并有一种忙碌感，把我们的大脑当作数字计算机处理器来对待。你只是给它输入指令，它一个接一个地执行，我认为我正在做的事情实际上更人性化。这种认为我们的大脑不像电脑，它不像我们知道的任何其他机器，它是你与之有个人联系的东西
and it's something that you really have to take care of, something that you have to coax high performance out of. So to have a structured day, for example, to protect your mind from distraction, I actually think makes you more human and less robotic than what most people do, which is to sit there like a human network router and just sort of process messages and tasks all day, like a blind computer processor. There seems to be a paradox here, because I think what I'm hearing you say is that scheduling yourself or even over scheduling yourself is the way to actually gain control over your
它是你必须真正照顾的东西，你必须从中诱导出高性能的东西。所以有一个结构化的一天，例如，保护你的大脑免受干扰，我实际上认为这让你更人性化，而不是像大多数人那样，坐在那里像一个人类网络路由器，整天处理消息和任务，像一个盲目的计算机处理器。这里似乎有一个悖论，因为我想我听到你说的是，安排自己甚至过度安排自己是真正获得对你的
life. Whereas people would sort of say if you're actually scheduling every second and sort of deciding four weeks ahead of time when you're going to stop work on a certain Wednesday, you've actually turned yourself into a robot. It's a paradox that shows up a lot. It confuses people, but I think you're right to point it out is that if you study, especially really creative people, professional creatives, they are surprisingly structured in how they approach their day.
生活控制权的方法。而人们会说，如果你实际上安排了每一秒，并且在四周前就决定了你什么时候要在某个周三停止工作，你实际上已经把自己变成了一个机器人。这是一个经常出现的悖论。它让人们感到困惑，但我认为你指出这一点是对的，即如果你研究，特别是非常有创造力的人，专业创意人员，他们在处理一天的方式上出奇地有结构。
I took a quote at one point from David Brooks to columnist, and I might be paraphrasing here, but basically, he pointed out this observation that great creative thinkers approach their time like accountants. That this is this great disconnect is that they're very structured and systematic about their time and produce the most unstructured brilliant creative insights. So it's a key paradox to point out because I really want to emphasize it. Adding structure and control to your time really can be the key to getting the biggest insights and most interesting work produced. I'm wondering if part of the tension comes about because we actually think of inspiration
我曾经引用过专栏作家大卫·布鲁克斯的一句话，我可能是在转述，但基本上，他指出了这个观察结果，即伟大的创造性思想家像会计师一样对待他们的时间。这种巨大的脱节是，他们对自己的时间非常有结构和系统，并产生了最非结构化的辉煌创造性见解。所以这是一个需要指出的关键悖论，因为我真的想强调它。为你的时间增加结构和控制确实可以是获得最大见解和产生最有趣工作的关键。我想知道这种紧张感是否部分源于我们实际上认为灵感
as being the thing that strikes us unexpectedly. And I think the case that you're making is that inspiration actually can be scheduled to arrive on command. Well, Chuck Close said the artist's inspiration is for amateurs. I think we over focus on the inspiration piece. If you're systematically pushing yourself and your knowledge and your craft, you will have inspiration. It'll happen in the shower, it'll happen while you walk to work. What's important is setting yourself up to have that inspiration and then giving yourself
是意外击中我们的东西。而我认为你提出的观点是，灵感实际上可以被安排按需到来。嗯，查克·克洛斯说艺术家的灵感是给业余爱好者的。我认为我们在灵感部分关注得太多了。如果你系统地推动自己、你的知识和你的手艺，你就会有灵感。它会发生在淋浴时，它会发生在你步行去上班时。重要的是让自己准备好获得那种灵感，然后给自己
the time and structure you need to act on it to actually produce something of value out of it. So I downplay the importance of inspiration and I emphasize the importance of creating a life or inspiration as possible and you're well suited to act on it. I want to ask you a couple of questions that push back against this idea from a practical standpoint, what if people are in workplaces where they have managers and bosses who aren't enlightened enough to say, yes, you should spend several hours engaged in deep work, people can't always choose for themselves what kind of work they pursue. Something that has seemed to be effective is in that type of situation, having a conversation with whoever your boss is, whoever supervises you.
你需要的时间和结构来采取行动，真正从中产生有价值的东西。所以我淡化了灵感的重要性，我强调了创造一种生活的重要性，让灵感成为可能，并且你非常适合采取行动。我想问你几个从实际角度反驳这个想法的问题，如果人们在工作场所，他们的经理和老板不够开明，不能说，是的，你应该花几个小时进行深度工作，人们不能总是为自己选择他们追求什么样的工作。在那种情况下，似乎有效的一件事是与你的老板，或者监督你的人进行对话。
And so I wanna talk about deep work. Here's what deep work is. And I wanna talk about non-deep worker shallow work. And here's what that is. And both are important to my job. And I wanna have a conversation and decide what should my ratio be? That is a typical work week.
所以我想谈谈深度工作。这就是深度工作。我想谈谈非深度工作或浅层工作。这就是那个。两者对我的工作都很重要。我想进行一次对话，决定我的比例应该是多少？那是一个典型的工作周。
What ratio of my hours should be deep work versus shallow work, and actually nailing down a number and aspirational target that everyone agrees, yeah, this is right for your position in our company. It's not saying, hey, boss, stop emailing me so much, you annoy me. Since that's saying, hey, let's try to optimize myself. So what should I be going for here? Let me get your feedback on this. And people are reporting back to me, tales of drastic changes to work cultures that they thought there's no way. There's no way I'm going to get away with this.
我的时间比例应该是深度工作与浅层工作，并实际上确定一个每个人都同意的数字和愿望目标，是的，这对于你在我们公司的职位是正确的。这不是说，嘿，老板，别再给我发那么多邮件了，你让我很烦。这是说，嘿，让我们尝试优化我自己。所以这里我应该追求什么？让我听听你对此的反馈。人们正在向我报告，他们认为不可能的工作文化发生了巨大变化。我不可能逃脱这个。
I'm supposed to be on Slack all the time or I'm supposed to be answering my emails all the time. They have this conversation in the next week. They're spending 50% of their hours undistracted. So I've been pushing that particular managerial hack as a good, positive way forward to trying to fix some of these issues. I'm wondering if some people might say your advice is really advice for people who in
我应该一直在线上Slack，或者我应该一直回复我的电子邮件。他们在下周进行了这次对话。他们有50%的时间是不受干扰的。所以我一直在推动那个特定的管理黑客，作为一种好的、积极的前进方式，试图解决其中一些问题。我想知道是否有些人可能会说你的建议确实是给那些在
some ways are at the top of their food chains. So if you have an author who basically is able to say I'm going to disconnect from the world for 18 months, I'm just going to focus on writing this book. You know, someone else is probably picking up after this person in all kinds of different ways. If Cal Newport says, you know, I'm going to close the door in my office. I'm not going to answer my phone. I'm not going to check my email. But someone needs to get in touch with you in an emergency. That person is probably going to reach an assistant of yours. And that assistant doesn't have the same luxury of deep work
某种程度上处于食物链顶端的人的建议。所以如果你有一位作者基本上能够说我将与世界断开18个月，我将只专注于写这本书。你知道，其他人可能在各种不同的方式上为这个人收拾残局。如果卡尔·纽波特说，你知道，我要关上办公室的门。我不接电话。我不检查电子邮件。但有人需要在紧急情况下联系你。那个人可能会联系你的助手。而那个助手没有同样的深度工作奢侈
as you do because he or she needs to be available to to hear what the emergency is or to hear what the request is. Does having a group of people who are engaged in deep work necessarily mean they must be essentially a second tier of workers who are engaged in shallow work to allow the deep thinkers to do their deep thinking? It doesn't require that, but it usually requires some type of reconfiguration of communication channels and expectations. So when I work, for example, with people maybe in a small consultancy that is client-facing, where they're used to this idea that clients need to reach us, issues pop up, what's important
像你一样，因为他或她需要随时待命以听到紧急情况是什么，或者听到请求是什么。拥有一群从事深度工作的人是否必然意味着他们必须基本上是从事浅层工作的二等工人，以允许深度思考者进行他们的深度思考？它不需要那样，但它通常需要某种沟通渠道和期望的重新配置。所以当我与可能在面向客户的小型咨询公司工作的人合作时，他们习惯于客户需要联系我们的想法，问题会出现，什么是重要的
there is just to actually change the communication expectations. That maybe instead of having a client just have individual people's email addresses, the company sets up an email address for that client. And the company has set up some agreement on there in that there'll always be someone monitoring that and here's the expectation of when you can get a response. Or maybe setting up a sometimes called the bat phone or emergency phone idea, where you say, okay, here's a number you can call me at. If there's an emergency when I'm in one of these
在那里只是为了真正改变沟通期望。也许公司不是让客户拥有个人的电子邮件地址，而是为该客户设置一个电子邮件地址。公司已经达成了一些协议，即总会有人监控它，这是你可以得到回复的期望。或者也许设置一个有时被称为“蝙蝠电话”或紧急电话的想法，在那里你说，好的，这是你可以打给我的号码。如果我在这些
deep work sessions, people set these up and say, they get called maybe once a year. So I don't think you need actual extra people involved to make space for deep work, but I do think it almost always requires some effort, some sort of reconfiguration of people's expectations on how and when they can reach you. So I'm going to ask you a question now that's part serious and part teasing. You and I was scheduled to talk last week and you didn't get the appointment down in your calendar and I was sitting here waiting for you.
深度工作会议中时有紧急情况，人们设置了这些并说，他们可能一年被叫一次。所以我认为你不需要实际额外的人员参与来为深度工作腾出空间，但我确实认为它几乎总是需要一些努力，某种对人们关于如何以及何时可以联系你的期望的重新配置。所以我现在要问你一个既严肃又带点戏谑的问题。你和我原定上周谈话，你没有把预约记在你的日历上，我当时坐在这里等你。
And of course, this kind of thing happens all the time, but in your case, I couldn't help but wonder, And of course, this kind of thing happens all the time, but in your case, I couldn't help but wonder did he miss this because he actually hadn't spent the time doing the shallow work to get this in his calendar? And is it possible that when we engage in deep work, we are essentially you know getting the benefit of all of that deep work, we're getting the deep thinking, we're getting the accomplishments, but some of the cost is born by other people, and they might actually be the people who are getting mad at you when they can't reach you. Well, it's a good point, and I think that's actually what happened.
当然，这种事情经常发生，但在你的情况下，我不禁想知道，当然，这种事情经常发生，但在你的情况下，我不禁想知道他错过这个是因为他实际上没有花时间做浅层工作把它记在日历上吗？而且是否可能当我们从事深度工作时，我们基本上你知道获得了所有那些深度工作的好处，我们获得了深度思考，我们获得了成就，但部分代价是由其他人承担的，而他们可能实际上是当他们无法联系到你时对你生气的人。嗯，这是一个很好的观点，我认为这实际上就是发生的事情。
Because I spend a lot of time working away for my computer, these type of problems happen to me more often. In this case, and I'm embarrassed it happened, but my vague memory was, I saw this communication on my phone because I had to be on there to send something to someone, but I was far away from a computer. And so I wasn't able to easily add it to a calendar. And I was like, okay, I'll remember to do this when I get back to my office next night for God.
因为我花了很多时间在电脑前工作，这些类型的问题更频繁地发生在我身上。在这种情况下，我很尴尬它发生了，但我模糊的记忆是，我在手机上看到了这个沟通，因为我必须在上面给某人发送东西，但我离电脑很远。所以我无法轻易地把它加到日历上。我想，好的，我回到办公室后会记得做这件事，结果我忘了。
And it did cause problems. And so I'm embarrassed about it. And that type of thing does happen. And I think this hits on a big point, which is deep work or a professional life focused on deep work, is less convenient for most people involved. But on the other hand, I want to put out there this notion that that might not be so bad.
它确实造成了问题。所以我对此感到尴尬。那种事情确实会发生。我认为这触及了一个大点，即深度工作或专注于深度工作的职业生活，对大多数相关人员来说不太方便。但另一方面，我想提出这个概念，即那可能并不那么糟糕。
It's possible that in this age of digital communication, we are focusing too much on convenience over effectiveness. I think in some ways what you're saying is also the tension between the short term and the long term. If I don't respond to a colleague's request or a manager's instructions to do something right away,
在数字通信时代，我们可能过于关注便利性而忽视了有效性。我认为在某种程度上你所说的是短期和长期之间的紧张关系。如果我不立即回复同事的请求或经理的指示去做某事，
it's irritating for the person at the other end of the line. And so I think most of us actually conformed to the social norm of saying, yes, I'm just going to be responsive, I'm going to be available, I'm going to answer the question as soon as it's asked. The point that you're making though is that they might be long-term goals, deeper institutional goals, that are essentially we're not thinking about. And of course, when those goals are not met because they're not articulated, no one notices their absence. So, people will notice it if you don't show up at an interview. People are not going to notice it if you don't write that bestseller or the next great idea.
这对电话另一端的人来说很烦人。所以我认为我们大多数人实际上都顺应了这种社会规范，即“是的，我会及时回复，我会随时待命，我会一收到问题就回答”。但你提出的观点是，可能存在一些长期的、更深层次的机构目标，而我们本质上并没有考虑到这些。当然，当这些目标因为没有被明确表达出来而无法实现时，没有人会注意到它们的缺失。所以，如果你不去参加面试，人们会注意到；但如果你没有写出那本畅销书或提出下一个伟大的想法，人们是不会注意到的。
And so, there's really a cultural bias in favor of the trivial over protecting what actually is most important. I really agree with that point, and I would add to it that I think a big part of it is lack of metrics. So if we look at two parallel case studies, two different industries, let's look at the industrial revolution and the rise of mass industrial production. This was a world where the metrics for productivity
因此，文化中确实存在一种偏见，即为了琐事而牺牲真正重要的事情。我非常同意这一点，我还想补充一点，我认为很大程度上是因为缺乏衡量标准。如果我们看看两个平行的案例研究，即两个不同的行业，让我们看看工业革命和大规模工业生产的兴起。那是一个生产力衡量标准非常明确的世界，
were very clear. How many cars per hour is our factory producing? And what we saw in that world, where bottom line value was very easy to measure, is that very quickly, the structure of work moved away from what was convenient for the workers and towards what produced more value. It moved away from the old system and factories where you had people working teams at one spot in the floor
比如工厂每小时生产多少辆汽车？在那个底线价值很容易衡量的世界里，我们看到工作结构很快就从方便工人的方式转向了能产生更多价值的方式。它远离了旧的工厂系统，即人们在车间的一个点上以团队形式工作，
to assemble the car towards things like the assembly line, which are incredibly inconvenient. It's very hard to manage the assembly line. It's very hard to get it right. It causes lots of issues. It's annoying, but it produces a lot more value. You move to digital knowledge work. We don't have those metrics. It's much harder to measure, okay, what's the cost to our bottom line if you're more
转向了装配线之类的方式，这非常不方便。管理装配线非常困难，要做好它也很难，而且会引发很多问题。这很烦人，但它能产生更多的价值。现在转向数字知识工作，我们没有这些衡量标准。衡量如果你更分心或更不分心，对我们底线的成本影响是什么，要困难得多。
distracted or less distracted? And so my conjecture is that without those metrics, we are going to fall back on these interpersonal or cultural biases. We're wired to be social, we don't want to upset someone. These type of biases take over because it's much harder to measure in this new world, the impact of different behaviors. I'm wondering if there's also a psychological explanation for the phenomenon you're describing. You know, I took a vacation a couple of weeks ago, and for the first time in a long time,
所以我的推测是，如果没有这些衡量标准，我们将退回到这些个人或文化偏见中。我们天生就是社会性的，不想让别人不高兴。这些类型的偏见占据了主导地位，因为在这个新世界里，衡量不同行为的影响要困难得多。我想知道你所描述的现象是否也有心理学上的解释。你知道，几周前我休假了，这是很久以来第一次，
I actually decided to unplug. So I didn't have internet access, I wasn't checking my email, I literally was cut off from things going on at work. And when I got back, there were a number of things that had happened in my absence, some of which I wish I'd had the chance to weigh in on. But when I looked at the aggregate, the overall conclusion I got was really that the world did just fine in my absence. Things went fine, I actually wasn't as indispensable as I thought I was.
我真的决定断开连接。所以我没有上网，没有查看电子邮件，我实际上与工作中发生的事情隔绝了。当我回来时，在我缺席期间发生了一些事情，其中一些我希望有机会发表意见。但当我审视整体情况时，我得出的总体结论确实是，没有我，世界照样运转得很好。事情进展顺利，我实际上并没有我想象中那么不可或缺。
I'm wondering if that might be a psychological driver in people being unwilling to actually cut themselves off, because not only might they discover that they are more productive, but they might also discover the world is just fine. Thank you very much without you. Yeah, I think that's one of three big psychological drivers that have led us to this world where now of the sort of constant connectivity business.
我想知道这是否可能是人们不愿真正切断联系的心理驱动因素，因为他们不仅可能发现自己效率更高，还可能发现没有他们，世界也很好。非常感谢没有你。是的，我认为这是导致我们进入这个充满持续连接业务的世界的三大心理驱动因素之一。
So that's certainly one, I think, this notion of, we get a sense of meeting and usefulness out of constantly being involved in interaction. I think the other two psychological drivers, one is just where we're wired to be tribal and it's very difficult for us psychologically to know there's an email waiting that we're not answering. And even if we know for a fact that the person who sent that message does not need a fast response, it still feels like we're at the tribal fire. And there's a tribe member standing there tapping you on the shoulder and you're ignoring them. We just have a very hard time with that. And I think the third driver is knowledge work is much less structured. And so how do you prove
所以这当然是一个，我认为，这种观念是，我们从不断的互动中获得了一种意义感和有用感。我认为另外两个心理驱动因素，一个是我们就天生具有部落属性，在心理上很难知道有一封电子邮件在等着我们而我们不去回复。即使我们确切地知道发送该消息的人不需要快速回复，感觉上我们仍然像是在部落的篝火旁。有一个部落成员站在那里拍你的肩膀，而你却无视他们。我们对此感到非常困难。我认为第三个驱动因素是知识工作结构化程度较低。那么你如何向你的组织或老板证明你的价值呢？
to your organization or to your boss that you're valuable and Business as a proxy for productivity is something that a lot of people have defaulted to well at the very least if you see I'm sending lots of messages you know I'm working and so I think those three different factors are all intertwined To get us to this place where we find ourselves just constantly sending messages as opposed to thinking hard thoughts or producing new things Cal Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. He's the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Well, thank you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyer.
把忙碌作为生产力的代理指标是很多人默认的做法。好吧，至少如果你看到我发送了很多消息，你就知道我在工作。所以我认为这三个不同的因素交织在一起，让我们处于这样一个境地：我们发现自己不断地发送消息，而不是进行深入思考或创造新事物。卡尔·纽波特是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授。他是《深度工作：在分心世界中获得成功的规则》一书的作者。卡尔，感谢你今天参加 Hidden Brain 节目。好的，谢谢你。本期 Hidden Brain 由 Raina Cohen 制作，Tara Boyer 编辑。
Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Laura Correll, Parts Shah and Thomas Lue. Our unsung hero this week is Stacey Foxwell. She's NPR's vice president of operations, which means she handles everything from where people sit to hiring the next generation of NPR journalists. Stacey keeps NPR running smoothly and she does so calmly, cheerfully, and with a remarkable sense of humor. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with one friend.
我们的团队包括 Jenny Schmidt、Laura Correll、Parts Shah 和 Thomas Lue。我们本周的无名英雄是 Stacey Foxwell。她是 NPR 的运营副总裁，这意味着她负责从人员座位安排到招聘下一代 NPR 记者的一切事务。Stacey 让 NPR 运行顺畅，她总是冷静、愉快，并具有非凡的幽默感。想了解更多 Hidden Brain 的内容，请在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与一位朋友分享。
We're always looking for new people to discover Hidden Brain. to share it with one friend. We're always looking for new people to discover hidden brain. Next week, we conclude our YouTube.o series with an episode about decision making. I realized that had you asked me a year earlier how I would be faring, the answer would have been, oh my gosh, I'll be devastated, but I wasn't devastated, it wasn't a good year, but it was okay. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们一直在寻找新的人来发现 Hidden Brain。与一位朋友分享。我们一直在寻找新的人来发现 Hidden Brain。下周，我们将以一集关于决策的内容结束我们的 YouTube.o 系列。我意识到，如果你一年前问我情况会如何，我的回答会是，天哪，我会崩溃的，但我并没有崩溃，那不是美好的一年，但还过得去。我是 Shankar Vedantam，这是 NPR。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。